des changements dès l'accueil aux
urgences de l'hôpital privé de
versailles le service administratif vous
reçoit de manière sécurisée au deuxième
confinement le service des urgences
s'est refait une beauté
une réorganisation du parcours à changy
pour le personnel soignant à un poste de
travail qui fait qu' il ya une plus
grande fluidité aussi des informations
du travail et à faciliter ainsi le
travail de chacun avec ses travaux les
urgences se voit doté de deux boxes
supplémentaires est accueillie avec plus
d'intimité et de confidentialité des
patients en hospitalisation très courte
durée avec trois chambres dont une
double téléconsultation été les
expertises sont aussi possibles
quand on a des certains cas par exemple
des de la neuro chirurgie cérébrale
on appelle la grande gare de
neurochirurgie transmet les images et le
même façon les grands gars de nouveaux
chiffres voir le patient l'examiner avec
des zooms important et et donner un avis
et voir s'il ya besoin de prendre le
patient alors plutôt que de le
transférer ces travaux représentent un
investissement de plus de 450 milles
euros
les urgences de l'hôpital privé de
versailles accueille 25 mille 500
passages par an